our chief legal correspondent Jen
Crawford is in Washington Jen good
morning two questions tell us about the
grand jury here and what this indictment
means well Charlie I mean this grand
jury has been meeting for several months
and this is essentially the beginning of
a criminal case against someone and I
mean what it tells us is that Muller
thinks that he can prove in court beyond
a reasonable doubt that the person who's
being indicted committed a crime but I
mean of course I mean these are
allegations what we're gonna hear today
and none of this is proven a grand jury
generally they'll charge you know
whatever the prosecution wants I mean
that's why you've probably heard that
expression a grand jury will indict a
ham sandwich well the interesting thing
too is what does it mean for the
president well I mean there is just a
lot we don't know right now I mean this
could be a bit player that we're not
even focused on who's far removed from
the president I mean we don't know if
this person will seek to Kontest the
indictment or to cooperate at me right
now you'd think they're not cooperating
prosecutors typically don't indict
people who are and you know here's the
thing I mean this person could always
change his mind decide to cooperate and
that would provide information and put
pressure on other witnesses and thanks
so much